I'm I liken back to 2020 and I think you
just said it 15 days to slow spread the
only reason in hell I would ever lock my
country down is because there was some
sort of flesh-eating virus tearing
through the population you never do that
to your country unless it was the last
ditch effort circumstance that you have
no other choice you lost running water
you lost soap if in those situations
maybe because you that that is the
recipe to destroy your country is to
shut it down don't do that again and
don't make people put dirty
masks on
nice I'm sick of it man I'm sick
of it I will not do it again
thank you
I wonder how many people feel exactly
the same way yeah I agree well you know
we're out in West Virginia so we came
out of here because we were in New
Jersey and it started getting really
intense there was talk locally about
shutting down the bridges out of New
Jersey and I was like I'm leaving I'm
not gonna stick around to wait and find
out if I'm trapped on this peninsula